this video is sponsored by Squarespace
the best way to make an amazing website
a lot of you guys have been asking us to
test the performance of the 16 inch
MacBook Pro when connected to an e GPU
so here it is and we're also gonna
compare it to our $15,000 Mac Pro to see
how this much less expensive EGP you
setup will fare
we're also making this video because
we've seen countless people buying a
GPUs for certain tasks that don't even
gain any extra performance from it I'll
show you what I mean in just a minute in
the video we posted just yesterday we
compared the graphics performance of the
top 3 AMD graphics cards and we ended up
choosing the $370 rx 5700 XT for this
test if you want to know why we chose
that card make sure to check out that
video at the end of this one for our a
GPU enclosure we went with a $300 razor
corer X which has proven itself as very
reliable bringing the total price of
this easy for you to 670 dollars now
Before we jump into our testing here are
the specs of each of these Macs we ended
up upgrading the RAM ourselves on the
Mac Pro so that saved us a couple
thousand dollars if you want to see how
we did that check out our DIY ram
upgrade guide at the end of this video
since our Mac Pro has a 12 core
processor there's a difference in
processing power but we're mostly going
to focus on graphics performance
starting off our testing with Geekbench
5s metal test the e GPU helps the 16
inch MacBook Pro get around two times
more raw graphics power but the Mac Pro
still scored around 54 percent higher
than the e GPU moving on to unit ins
heaven benchmark which simulates real
world gaming performance the Mac Pro got
around 38% more FPS than the 5700 XT now
for the blender benchmark which runs the
BMW in-classroom rendering tests the
each of you surprisingly beats out the
Mac Pro the reason for this is because
the 5700 XT is built on AMD's latest
Navi graphics architecture compared to
the Mac Pros Vega 2 card which is using
the older Vega tech but it's still not
too far behind because it has so much
raw power now getting into video editing
with Final Cut Pro get ready for some
shocking results
I bet none of you are expecting in the
5k Bruce X benchmark the Mac Pro wipes
the floor with the Egypt you set up
finishing over three times faster than
the 57 but here's the shocker the 16
inch MacBook Pro is actually faster by
itself compared to using an e GPU this
probably makes no sense at all to you
guys especially if you're spending
almost $700 for an e GPU setup so let me
explain what's happening here right
after this word from our sponsor
Squarespace if you've been thinking
about making your own website
Squarespace is seriously the best way to
go
I built an engaging website from my
wife's cleaning business with literally
no web making experience you just choose
a template customize blocks of text and
images and easily move them around it's
incredibly simple affordable and it's
been running flawlessly for over two
years bringing in new clients thanks to
his built-in SEO tools so whether you're
making a website for a small business or
literally anything else go to
squarespace.com for a free trial and use
our custom link below when you're ready
to launch - save 10% on your first
purchase of a website or domain now
let's get back to why the EGP U is
giving us worse performance in this test
because the graphics card in an HB you
is set up externally there are some
major in efficiencies in certain
graphics tests first off all of the
graphics data has to go through the
fundable 3 cable to reach the MacBook
Pro which ends up limiting performance
on top of that for certain tests like
brus X the graphics card and processor
need to communicate with each other so
graphics data is constantly going back
and forth within the same cable at the
same time this means that the
Thunderbolt 3 cables data bandwidth gets
cut in half which doesn't happen for
things like gaming since data only goes
one way from the MacBook Pro to the each
of you and then to the display it
doesn't have to go back and forth like
it does in Bruce X so be aware that in
some tests and each of you can actually
kill your performance to further prove
my point check out the results from this
five-minute 4k h.264 export which is the
most common format that youtubers use
for their videos the MacBook Pro by
itself finished almost twice as fast can
here too using the e GPU which is again
due to the in efficiencies of using the
graphics card externally but the story
is actually not the same for all of the
tests we ran we stabilized 1/32 Canon
raw 60p clip and the each of you greatly
helped the performance of the macbook
pro because in this test data doesn't
have to travel back and forth within the
same cable the performance was so good
that it was only two seconds behind the
mac pro which is really impressive
next we exported a five-minute version
of the same canon raw clip and yet again
the macbook pro was faster by itself and
the mac pro ends up way ahead proving
itself in his test not only that but the
mac pro is capable of playing this raw
footage back at 95 frames per second
compared to around 58 with the e GPU
which is finally an improvement over the
macbook pro by itself we then exported a
five-minute 30 frames per second HEV C
clip and both machines actually finished
in exactly the same time and that's
because they're both taken advantage of
Apple's t2 chip and it's dedicated HEV C
encoding which is actually limited to 60
frames per second or exactly 2 minutes
and 30 seconds for a five-minute clip
with the e GPU the data has to get sent
to it to decode and then back to the
MacBook Pros t2 chip to encode so it
ends up taking twice as long now let's
move on to some of the more extreme
tests in Final Cut Pro starting with the
5-minute 5k Redrock to 4k export here
the Mac Pro wipes the floor with the
MacBook Pro finishing around three times
faster because this footage is extremely
dependent on processor performance which
is lacking on the MacBook Pros 8 core
CPU moving on we decided to throw in
some pro res raw tests as well since our
Mac Pro features the $2000 afterburner
card we started off by exporting a
five-minute 4k Pro res raw clip and the
Mac Pro finished over three times faster
thanks to the afterburner in this test
the e GPU actually helps out a bit but
not enough to make it worth it now
running the same test but with an ake a
clip we see pretty much the same results
with the Mac Pro finishing around three
times faster but we do see a bigger
improvement with the e GPU as far as
timeline playback the
Pro with the afterburner card can run
four streams of 8k 24p ProRes raw
footage all at the same time which
amounts to 96 frames per second total
the MacBook Pro can't even handle one
stream at full speed only being able to
run it at 19 frames per second or 22 if
you add the e GPU but it's still shy of
the perfect 24 frames per second
playback now without the afterburner
card even the fully specked out $53,000
mac pro can only handle three streams of
this footage so afterburner is a
must-buy for anyone who's working with
pro res footage and is considering a mac
pro now moving on to DaVinci Resolve 16
we exported the same 5-minute Canon raw
clip and the Mac Pro finished over twice
as fast as the MacBook Pro and here the
each of you didn't help at all now
testing timeline playback in the same
test the ETP you greatly killed the
performance of the MacBook and the Mac
Pro is capable of getting over four
times the FPS we then tested 4k
Blackmagic Raw noise reduction and this
time the e GPU helped a lot getting
close to double the FPS but of course
nowhere near the speed of the Mac Pro
and finally there's one task that you
absolutely should not buy an e GP you
for and that's photo editing we exported
500 RAW images to JPEG and the EGP you
did literally nothing at all for the 16
inch MacBook Pro and the Mac Pro was
much quicker because of the better CPU
and more RAM now all these results might
shock you seeing as the EGP you actually
made the MacBook slower in a lot of the
tests but keep in mind that we're using
the latest 16 inch MacBook Pro that is
quite a bit faster than the previous 15
inch models and that's before you
consider the newer technology and
encoders so based on all of these tests
there are really only two reasons why
you should buy an e GPU for your 16 inch
macbook pro one is if you want to do
some gaming as we saw a major boost and
gaming performance into as if you're
doing graphics rendering like using
blender as we saw a doubling and
performance but for everything else it's
honestly not really worth it and the mac
pro of course is a different beast at a
very different price point but the
MacBook Pro still fears extremely well
considering the lower price and it being
portable so it makes a lot more sense
for most people if this video helped you
out
tap the like button click the circle
about to subscribe and check out those
two videos that I mentioned earlier in
this video thanks for watching and we'll
see you in the next one
[Music]